this is not my war this is our war and
you all didn't start it the
establishment started it but I will tell
you one thing you all are going to
finish it there's a time and season for
everything and right now it's a season
of war against a GOP establishment Steve
batten over the weekend saying he's
going to war with the GOP establishment
we saw it in Alabama today President
Trump said
Paden has a lot of good points but he's
going to try and work with Mitch
McConnell in the interim here with
reaction to all of this the author of
the best-selling book defeating jihad
they make America great again coalition
chief strategist and former deputy
assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka and former Obama
economic adviser close friend of Hannity
Austan Goolsbee is with us Austin I know
you're gonna like a little of this but
your party has zero vision and when
there's no vision or insight that people
perish so we've already perished under
Obama I want to say this I'm with Steve
Bannon in this sense we can't lose
control of the House and Senate but if
Mitch McConnell can't do his job
go get out and let's not elect people
that aren't bold and gonna fight to get
the job done what they did on health
care was a disgrace mmm just look at the
last nine months
what has the GOP establishment done for
this president on November the 8th the
people of America chose they chose a
person who was anti-establishment who
had a very clear message Obamacare
national security the economy the border
what's happened what is the GOP done
nothing absolutely nothing there's
something amazing that's happening on
climate on trade on look what he did
last week on health what he did last
week the president on his own on health
care was brilliant and it's gonna help
every American form an association then
you have the benefit of corporations its
buying power buying across state lines
not subject to ACA or state laws it's
stunning after this speech that Steve
and I gave I by the way your speech is
great I'm not sure i sat down with about
half a dozen true Trump Whitehouse
people afterwards block away from the
White House and I said to them so who's
giving the president advice
on Obamacare on on the jcpoa and they
said you know what
nobody he's getting the opposite advice
and what's he doing like a steam train
he's just he's blasting legacies almost
single-handedly now Austin I know you're
probably happy that you get to fight out
more I got a question for you what what
is the Democratic vision for the country
what do they want to do for the country
give us the top five items go look I
think what I wants to do what they
should want to do where the top there is
an argument within the Democratic Party
number one one restore wage growth to
working people or do you mean like Obama
did okay - yeah in the last three years
of Obama last three years last wages
going up yeah simply only 1381 food
stamps eight million more in poverty but
what's number two I know that was John
your quote numbers from three years ago
I'm quoting numbers over the eight years
of Obama forbidding keep them
accountable maintain the expansion of
health care o grow Obama care is not
great in it would be great point is with
President Obama and with President Bush
and with President Clinton all three of
them had major legislative
accomplishments in their first year
Donald Trump has done he's got Congress
and he's fighting with his own party and
making I think it's healthy I'm gonna
tell you why and dr. korkor if I think
politicians are all governed by fear mmm
I saw a very fearful Mitch McConnell
today and I think the reason corker got
out is he knew he was gonna get he was
gonna get primary and I saw that's why
he's now lashing it winds of change
they're worried this weekend Steve's
speech my speech
we rattle their cage and this is the
right message to send because you know
what your letter does what they do and
that's fine that's okay we expect the
left to do that for ideological reasons
but when our side that says they have
our values get selected in the
raised us and does nothing in Capitol
Hill that's the bigger obstacle you know
what you know one truth and I'll say
this to Austin Austin I will give your
party credit you guys stick together
through thick and thin and there's not
one person that wavers Republicans
aren't like that so I can see what are
the other three what are the other three
big vision expanding Obamacare and
fulfilling my Obama's economic we how
can you not dwell on the fact that the
Republican governors have now come out
and said what Donald Trump's proposing
on health care would be catastrophic to
States they're 19 74 where they can buy
because they have offices in different
cities they are not subject to state
rules or Obamacare rules they can buy in
bulk at lower prices better plans across
state lines with more competition
including cooperatives health agents
have some bipartisan ideas don't just go
light everything you can see online crap
that's going to support President Trump
you guys just oppose him because he
breathed they won't support president
trip he gave every American a million
because he thought through
even Republicans are safe they say he
can swim but he can't give us the fiber
and I said look look at the economy
we've just broken what the last twenty
eight record the host has to say no we
just broke the 46th record record
historic records and that's good for
everybody you don't have to have shares
your 401 K if you've got a retirement
plan you're making money we have
increased by a quarter the wealth of the
stock market by the way stay you know
Austin you were part of the the
foundational team that that for the
Obama economy how is it he's the first
president in American history to
accumulate more debt than every other
president before him combined a and B
never reach ammonia that's never reached
one year of his presidency 3% GDP growth
and
the debt there is one significant break
from the Obama legacy that I will admit
and that is in the time that Donald
Trump has been in office job creation
has been about 20 percent lower than
she's made a million jobs and eight
million new jobs that you wake up where
are you living
Chicago that's why just look at the
numbers yawn
we're grow we've added about 1/4 we had
people on the outside Steve myself to
make America great coalition we are
dismantling Obama's disastrous legacy
brick by brick join us I'm in McConnell
get on board or get out of the way